all right let's take one more question
here we go hi jason i'm lance i'm the
founder of yapper so yapper is a
community moderated social network
where users can vote on whether or not
posts should or should not stay
in the platform but aside from that i'm
also a college student right now
so my question for you is are there any
advice or tips that you can give me
as i move forward being a startup
founder and also a student
i just realized there's a lot of things
to do here so how do i manage my time
and effort between the two
and also how do i know it's the right
time to i guess
jump ship and leave one for the other
thank you very much and
i hope you guys actually check out
yapper thank you lance great question
this is a great and encouraging sign you
are
in school and you have a startup so you
have this incredible optionality and
i think if you're going to school and
you're not running up debt
and you want to finish that's great you
might be halfway done
you might be two-thirds of the way done
there's nothing wrong with enjoying your
time there
looking at it as an education somewhere
between a vacation
and a delightful moment in your life
to meet friends have fun but if the
startup is getting traction
and you love it and your hearts in it
and you think that this is the
the future of your life you can also
pause school and you know it will always
be there
it's not going anywhere in fact they
kind of need people and it's the middle
of a pandemic
so staying in school in the middle of a
pandemic i think a lot of people would
question
whether it's worth paying that money for
for zoom classes and maybe it actually
is a good time
so i i think it's a it's one of these
situations where
if your heart's gonna really go for a
long walk and figure out where your
heart is if
your heart's really in the startup and
you feel like it's got a shot
uh at you know becoming something big
and important in the world then do it
why not your parents might give you
other advice i think the default advice
is to stay in school
but you can't give that default advice
anymore because school's always going to
be there
and school is expensive and school this
typically does not match the skills that
you need
when you graduate to generate income so
it's just a bad
bum deal and and a lot of people got
hoodwinked and
bamboozled taken that deal i think
that's a large part of why millennials
kind of lean towards socialism because
they're like this is bs i spent 150k
i went to graduate school after that and
spent another 75 km 200 250k in debt and
these debts don't equal a great job what
happened you told me
you told me this narrative and what
happened was the price of education
went three or four x of what it should
be if your education is costing you five
grand a year
10 grand a year seems reasonable you get
a 50k job when you graduate no problem
but if you're spending 50k a year you
might want to think that through and you
can always make your startup into a
project
so is this a project or is this actually
a real startup and what's going to look
better on your resume when you get out
in the real world i mean it's a really
interesting
thing to think about for me if i was
hiring you to work at a company and you
had three years of college and two years
running your own startup that looks
better to me
than four years in college and uh you
know whatever an internship no shame in
the game if you got to pay the bills i
had to do it myself
but you know the startup and having
skills is what it's all about
being entrepreneurial is what it's all
about so again if it's a project and you
don't think it's really going anywhere
you're unsure
you can keep it as a project you have to
turn it off but if you feel like
this is your facebook this is your uber
this is your tesla
yeah i wouldn't worry about you can
always go back to school and it's a
pandemic so
who cares it's like taking your office
you get that kind of free pass right
it's not like you're missing much it's
not like you're on campus having like
some great party and there's some
awesome party tonight that you're
missing